pas de musique pas de pancartes pas de
figurants derrière le chef
tout un contraste avec les
rassemblements politiques qu'on nous
présente depuis le début de la campagne
dont le camp néo démocrates
le ton est posé l'heure est à la mise au
point ne nous lassons pas distraire le
npd veut éviter que l'enjeu du niqab
viennent déstabiliser sa campagne
thomas mulcair contre attaquent les
conservateurs ont franchi la ligne avec
l'intention de faire peur aux canadiens
ils veulent des nouveaux citoyens qui
prête serment à visage découvert
depuis des jours les conservateurs
jouent à fond cette carte encore
aujourd'hui steven bleynie rappelé
fièrement la position de son parti et le
19 octobre le choix est clair avec un
gouvernement conservateur nous avons
l'intention dans les 100 premiers jours
de réintroduire la loi sur le serment de
citoyenneté
le ministre sortant se tenait au côté
d'un candidat qui avait affiché sa façon
de penser sur son compte facebook
visiblement les conservateurs croient
avoir trouvé une faille chez le npd un
point de désaccord entre le parti il est
québécois mais thomas mulcair qui ne
veut surtout pas se mettre les électeurs
à dos cherche lui aussi à toucher une
corde sensible
après des décennies de luttes féministes
au québec
je comprends que le port du niqab par
une femme puisse créer un malaise et
mains de la colère et ils rappellent les
politiques d'inclusion de son parti mais
si certaines de ces femmes sont
opprimées
il faut les aider et ce n'est pas en les
privant de leur citoyenneté canadienne
et de leurs doigts qu'on va y arriver
thomas mulcair avait d'abord joué de
prudence dans ce débat sur le niqab mais
les attaques de ses adversaires le force
à aborder la question de front
et si madeleine desmaures et radio
canada ottawa